[Musik]
also ich glaube nicht alles was die
medien sagen weil da wird garantiert
auch einiges was man nicht
veröffentlichen darf
dass da irgendwie zensiert wird aber
nicht von den medien selber sondern dass
es noch von oben kommt ich vertraue den
öffentlichen medien und ja bei den
privatmedien richter eher zwiegespalten
ich vertraue mir den medien als nicht
vertrauen ja aber es gibt schon artikel
die ich mich frage das wirklich so ist
ja wenn man es wirklich ein eigenes bild
schaffen will muss man eben sehr viel
lesen und hören und sich an die medien
würden sie sagen warum warum weil nicht
mehr berichtet wird wie wirklich in
deutschland ist um die deutsche politik
steht und um die deutschen bevölkerung
überhaupt war alle tote spiel gut
ob in einem land mit meinungsfreiheit
und mit freier presse wirklich etwas
totgeschwiegen werden kann darüber
diskutieren wir jetzt herzlich
willkommen bei phoenix unsere
gesprächsrunde zwischen hass und
meinungsfreiheit wie werden die medien
ihrer verantwortung gerecht so viel
nämlich vorweg bei uns wird heute nicht
totgeschwiegen wir wollen
selbstkritischen offen diskutieren und
das zum internationalen tag der
pressefreiheit sechs gäste mit sechs
meinungen die wir ihnen jetzt vorstellen
anja reschke die innenpolitik leiterin
ndr fernsehen hat für ihre tagesthemen
kommentare zustimmung und schützt uns
bekommen und plädiert dennoch dafür
haltung zu zeigen
stefan aust herausgeber der welt meint
manche medien sind zu sehr partei und
ein allzu großes sendungsbewusstsein
verschleiert den blick auf die realität
teresa bücker die chefredakteurin des
magazins edition f sagt um vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen müssen medien wissen
was ihre leser bewegt der
medienwissenschaftler norbert bolz warnt
vor gesinnungs realismus bottini at
die ard-korrespondentin sagt mir
bereitet es sorge dass die
pressefreiheit sich in den vergangenen
jahren kontinuierlich verschlechtert hat
und auch in demokratien angriffe auf
medien und presse zum alltag gehören
george weinberg von den republiken saw
the seas camps donald trump persönlich
und wirft den deutschen medien vor den
amerikanischen präsidenten einseitig und
falsch darzustellen
auch darüber wollen wir jetzt
diskutieren herr weinberg wie gut kennen
sie denn donald trump persönlich ja ich
kann ihn kenne ich also aus beruflicher
meine beruflichen tätigkeit in den 80er
jahren habe ich ihn kennengelernt und
ich bin dann politisch aktiv bei der
republikaner und war ich jetzt
eingeladen zum weihnachtsfest nach
washington dc jetzt weiter aus ob er ins
weiße haus zusammen mit dem trick mit
dem richard green etwa botschaft der
neue us botschafter waren wir im weißen
haus und haben uns die rede vom
weihnachtsrede angeschaut und angehört
die der präsident dort geführt werden
drei tage später waren wir auch noch
beim vice president beim benz was
schätzen sie an dolmetschern was ich
einen schätzel hat sehr viel gutes wir
haben hacker gemacht die economy booms
bruttoinlandsprodukt 3,1 prozent im
letzten jahr waren es fast 4 prozent
fünf neue 5 millionen neue jobs davon
fast 600.000 im gewerblichen bereich hat
die steuerreform durchgeführt
80 prozent der amerikaner amer dollars
in der tasche und er macht auch sehr
viel für die minorities für die
afrikaner
und es ist einfach ein guter präsident
hat auch sachen international angepackt
die die folgenden präsidenten nicht so
intensiv angegangen sind kann sie dieses
hat die chinesen glaube ich in die
schränke gebracht und er macht viel
gehabt im internationalen pakt hermann
ott das eine ist ja die politische
bewertung das andere heute bäume über
die medien sprechen und finden sie wenn
sie ihn politisch unterstützen finden
sie es genauso richtig wenn der us
präsident die medien feind des
amerikanischen volkes nennt man muss ein
bisschen ausholen
die medien in amerika waren immer
besonders kritisch den republikanischen
präsidenten
das fing schon bei den anträgen der als
als durchschnittliche schauspieler von
den medien bezeichnet worden ist und wir
wissen das ist eine große präsident war
der auch steuerlich sehr viel für usa
gemacht hat und die sowjetunion ist also
auch zusammengebrochen durch seine
politik dann der donald der bush senior
der jetzt vor kurzem gestorben ist der
eben in der presse jetzt war er tot war
auch gelobt worden ist als er präsident
war hat man in ein rip genannt also was
heißt und mehr oder weniger blind wenn
ich da einen haken darf aber keiner
dieser republikanischen präsidenten
hätte ja diese wortwahl genutzt und
gesagt die medien in usa sind feind des
volkes kommt aus new yorker
geschäftsmann dessen kein politiker
redet nicht um den brei herum
es sagt das was er meint und das was
auch sitzt also 80 prozent amerikaner
verstehen seine sprache
im gegensatz zu obama weiß vielleicht 30
prozent nur wussten wovon er redet und
das ist eine ausdrucksweise die ich
persönlich vielleicht bisschen
grenzwertig halte aber es ist so dass
eben das auch verstanden wird und wenn
man sieht wie die medien der donald
trump von anfang an behandelt haben wie
negativ nicht nur ihn seine familie
seine frau seine kinder dass die 13 e
version wo der mann unterstellt dass er
authentisch ist dann würde mich nicht
dass er dann natürlich auch ich sag mal
zurückliegt sei so eine positionierung
eines präsidenten gegenüber den medien
mit so einer wortwahl
das kannte man sonst von us-präsidenten
nicht sie waren viele jahre
korrespondent in unter anderem in moskau
und haben auch aus der ukraine berichtet
eigentlich denkt man da ja eher an
länder wie russland
wenn man so etwas hört ja vor allen
dingen wenn ich den begriff find das
volk höre dann werde ich tatsächlich an
russland und an die geschichte russlands
erinnert ist das ein stalinistischer
begriff und ich denke man sollte sehr
bewusst mit diesem begriff umgehen und
die nicht einfach so in die öffentliche
debatte werfen
donald trump tochter ivanka trump hat
sich ja auch von dem begriff distanziert
und hat gesagt dass sie das nicht so
pauschal sagen kann woraufhin dann der
präsident selbst das auch noch mal ein
bisschen relativiert hat und gesagt hat
er meint natürlich die fake news medien
und da bin ich dann bei dem nächsten
schlagwort fake news ein wort das der
us-präsident sehr sehr oft benutzt was
wiederum viele andere autokraten
ermuntert sich auch auf fake news zu
berufen fake news presse gesetze zu
erlassen medien gesetze zu erlassen und
damit jede kritische berichterstattung
zum beispiel über den kreml auch zu
delegitimieren und das sehen wir gerade
in russland und darüber wollen mit
leicht diskutieren schauen wir uns erst
mal an was mein kollege philipp wunder
sie zusammengestellt hat zu sams
verhältnis zu den medien in den usa und
soweit ein mann und sein besonderes
verhältnis zur wahrheit
obama sei nicht in den usa geboren den
klimawandel gebe es nicht und auch
trumps erster amtstag begann mit einer
lüge
angeblich sollen die medien die zahl der
zuschauer bei seiner amtseinführung
gefälscht haben fake news dabei waren
weniger menschen zum capitol gekommen
als 2009
bei präsident obama üblicherweise gelten
staatliche autoritäten als sogenannte
privilegierte quellen für uns als
journalistinnen und journalisten
das heißt tendenziell kann man sich auf
sie verlassen und wenn das nicht der
fall ist ist das ein riesen skandal in
der endphase des us wahlkampfes wurden
die 20 erfolgreichsten falschmeldungen
öfter geteilt geliked und kommentiert
als die 20 erfolgreichsten berichte
seriöser medien
donald trump nutzt seinen
twitter-account immer häufiger als
pressestelle immer wieder beschimpft
trump dort auch journalisten als feinde
des amerikanischen volkes
dass sie am ende beispielsweise ist
feind des volkes für ihn ganz egal wie
positiv oder negativ sie über ihn
berichten und foxnews beispielsweise
sieht er quasi als haussender und viele
bei foxnews beugen sich dem auch fox and
friends die vier gesehene morning schon
in den letzten jahren hat sie sich zum
sprachrohr films entwickelt kritik
fehlanzeige
echte kritiker werden stattdessen von
ihm diskreditiert jetzt ist es aber so
mit diesem präsidenten donald trump dass
so viele falschdarstellung und von ihm
veröffentlicht werden
dass es gar nicht mehr so einfach ist
zwischen lüge und wahrheit zu
unterscheiden und wenn die kolleginnen
und kollegen das machen dann einfach
wüst beschimpft werden
donald trump und die medien hunderte
zeitungen haben mittlerweile gewarnt vor
einer gefährdung der pressefreiheit
durch den us-präsidenten heraus wir
hören dass gerade am ende des des
beitrags es gab einen moment wo sich
viele zeitungen usa zusammengetan haben
und zusammen sich gegen diese behauptung
gestellt haben sie sei ein feind des
volkes war das ein notwendiges zeichen
und wäre so etwas in deutschland auch
möglich ist das richtig an so einer
stelle dass die zeitung sich zusammentun
naja erstmal müsste man mal so einen
groben präsidenten beziehungsweise
kanzler oder kanzlerin haben der sich so
verhält oder die sich so verhält wie
trump das tut das ist ja schon sehr
ungewöhnlich und wie man so sagt auf den
groben klotz gibt es manchmal im groben
keil
das ist umgekehrt auch so aber man darf
natürlich nicht ganz vergessen dass sich
die verhältnisse in den letzten jahren
durch das internet gewaltig verändert
haben aber ganz gewaltig verändert haben
ich meine überlegen sie was deutsche
kanzler schon über die medien gesagt
haben an konrad adenauer ein abgrund von
landesverrat das ist auch nicht so viel
anders gegenüber dem spiegel dass auch
nicht so viel anders als das was er
jetzt sagt mit feinden des volkes und
was hat helmut schmidt alles über
journalisten abgelästert da gibt es
viele viele beispiele das einzige was
ich wirklich gewaltig verändert hat ist
dass alle diese dinge natürlich im
internet aufgegriffen werden und dann
wie durch einen katalysator verstärkt
werden und dadurch plötzlich die
öffentliche debatte auf eine andere
weise bestimmen als das früher der fall
gewesen ist
aber ich finde wir als journalisten wir
haben politiker immer angegriffen und
heftig kritisiert wahrscheinlich immer
zurecht vielleicht ganz selten auch mal
zu unrecht ich natürlich immer nur zu
recht ist ja klar aber ich finde wir
sollten da auch nicht so empfindlich
sein wenn wir politiker angreifen dürfen
uns auch nicht wundern wenn die mal
irgendwie grob zurückschlagen
solange das system funktioniert so dass
sie uns nicht sozusagen den arbeitsplatz
nehmen können oder das recht auf
meinungsfreiheit kappen können dann wird
es natürlich ganz ernst wenn zb die
parteien was öffentlich rechtliche
anstalten anbetrifft einfluss nehmen auf
personalbesetzungen und dergleichen so
das hat es auch in den vergangenen
jahren immer wieder gegeben und zwar
sehr groß
also ich kann mich hierhin sinn ich war
ja viele jahre beim ndr also in der ard
die panorama und aufgrund der brokdorf
berichterstattung über das atomkraftwerk
brokdorf das damals im bau war da
wollten die parteien vor einigen die cdu
ganz vorne am besten den ndr zerschlagen
also das ist so neu nicht
herr bolz die washington post hat
zusammengefasst das trump
durchschnittlich bisher seit amtsantritt
bis ende 2018 gegen diese ausstellung
pro tag etwa elf falsche oder
irreführende aussagen von sich gegeben
hat ist es aufgabe der medien ist es
richtig dass eine zeitung wie die
washington post das so bewertet und
aufstellt und darauf hinweist
ja ich weiß nicht ob es eine bewertung
ist oder einfach ein analytisches
ergebnis das kann ich nicht beurteilen
denkbar ist dass ich halte es nicht für
ausgeschlossen aber unsere thema ist
glaube ich ein bisschen anders gelagert
und man sollte es nicht auf die
empfindlichkeit des weltturniers muss
gegenüber einem politiker reduzieren der
in einer art auftritt gegenüber der welt
journaille wie noch nie zuvor niemand
anders ich glaube es stimmt schon mit
dem mit mit dem gegenseitig aufeinander
einprügeln das ist glaube ich die
voraussetzung der ganzen sache denn
eines war in dem ein spieler ja
eindeutig nicht wahr
1 kommentar den journalisten gegeben hat
nämlich zu sagen ja wenn sie n n
berichtet über trump ob das jetzt
positiv oder negativ ist wir gelten als
als feinde des volkes ich guck sehr oft
cnn
und ich habe noch nie irgendetwas
positives über job gehört in diesem
sender und das gilt nicht nur für für
cnn das können sie in deutschland
genauso beobachten
er mag ja ein schrecklicher mensch sein
vielleicht ein schlimmer präsident
vielleicht macht er alles falsch aber
ich glaube es gibt auch nicht den ansatz
des versuchs einer objektiven
berichterstattung über trump
das gilt für deutschland genauso wie
soweit ich es beurteilen kann für
amerika und da steckt glaube ich ein
ernsthaftes problem und das hängt auch
mit dem gesamtthema zusammen ich denke
ich will nicht sagen dass trump zur
notwehr lüge greift aber dass er im
grunde da einen eine wie sie sagen eine
gegenwelt gegen die er massiv vorgeht
und das natürlich vor allen dingen mit
dem neuen medium den digitalen medien
mit twitter auch eine muss man zugeben
geniale idee auf die bisher auch noch
niemand gekommen ist mit twitter welt
politik zu machen also unter umgehung
aller klassischen massenmedien das ist
schon eine interessante und wie ich
finde es sehr intelligente art und weise
gegenöffentlichkeit zu produzieren naja
also viele punkte angesprochen über die
wir gleich sprechen frau reschke
plötzlich wenn wir donald trump sehen
und hören geht es um alternative fakten
wird über die wahrheit oder über fakten
diskutiert was passiert da ich glaube
das problem was man als journalist oder
vielleicht auch als mensch in
deutschland hat mit donald trump ist
jetzt gar nicht so sehr unbedingt die
bewertung seiner einzelnen politischen
leistungen oder misserfolge ich glaube
dass es für die meisten menschen hier
gar nicht so einfach zu bewerten sondern
diese aussagen die halt immer wieder
kommen die ein politisches system
untergraben oder eine demokratie
angreifen es ging ja nicht nur gegen die
presse es ging auch gegen die justiz das
ging auch gegen grundsätzliche
menschenrechte natürlich erschüttert ein
bis wenn er einfach mal zeit aus dem
klima abkommen aussteigt so dass er
natürlich alles so so dinge gewesen die
ein irritiert haben an diesem
präsidenten und wenn du jemanden hast
der sagt also dachte ich jetzt ärgert
über journalisten das kann ich verstehen
und da haben sie vollkommen recht es gab
auch in deutschland kanzler die sich
über journalisten geärgert haben aber
ist etwas anderes ob man sich über eine
berichterstattung ärgert
ob man unisono die presse die ja einen
teil dieser demokratie ist sozusagen in
grund und boden rammt und die einzigen
die sozusagen noch geltung haben für ihn
fox news sind die an seinen lippen
hängen und alles was er sagt gut finden
das finde ich dann in dem kräftespiel
und auch in dem in der rolle die medien
in der demokratie haben schwierig und
ich glaube deswegen tut man sich damit
so ein bisschen schwer
ich muss ich mich noch eine sache sagen
ich muss jetzt doch den ndr verteidigen
das ist natürlich 40 jahre herne
die braucht also fast 40 jahre her dass
war der antrag oder achtziger also schon
mal viel denn nicht schon damals
damals hatte sich anfangs war der
einfluss sehr sehr sehr genau so alt wie
ich weiß also im beim ndr was so wenn
der wenn die mehrheiten in den drei
bundesländern so waren das die cdu
bestimmte war der intendant cdu der
stellvertrende inland intendant spd der
programmdirektor dürfte wie der cdu sein
und bei machtwechseln wassern umgekehrt
dass dieses szenario aber solange es mit
nikolaus brender zum beispiel beim zdf
nicht klärt in ende einfluss genommen
worden ist beteiligen sie den in der das
war nicht mit kritik am ende die heime
seien an die politischen parteien die
einfluss genommen haben und das ist zum
glück in der tat etwas durchgedrückt
aber auch in der zeitung übrigens einer
guck mal
bleiben wir noch mal kurz mit dem
stichwort fakten frau kann es eigentlich
ein streit über fakten über wahrheit
geben nein kann es auch keinen fall
und ich glaube das ist was sowohl trump
als auch andere rechtspopulisten
versuchen wenn sie mit dem begriff
meinungsfreiheit operieren
also trump oder auch die
rechtspopulisten in deutschland die
haben eine ganz andere auffassung von
meinungsfreiheit als die ursprünglich
definiert ist weil die rechtspopulisten
finden dass meinungsfreiheit bedeutet
alles sagen zu dürfen und auch zu lügen
rassistisch beleidigen zu dürfen
menschenrechte in frage stellen zu
dürfen
und das fällt ja nicht unter
meinungsfreiheit und es ist ja schwierig
oder es auch keine journalistische
aufgabe lügen und wahrheit als
gleichberechtigte meinung nebeneinander
zu stellen
herr bolz sie als medienwissenschaftler
dort fakten wahrheit kann es da
verschiedene meinungen zu geben kann man
darüber streiten ist leider nicht so das
so einfach wäre lügen vor
wahrheit zu unterscheiden alles was
überhaupt berichtet wird ist eine art
konstruktion sie können immer nur hoch
selektiv über die welt berichten sie
müssen ausschnitte wählen
vor allen dingen ist sind massenmedien
gezwungen und das ist sehr wichtig in
unserem zusammenhang jedes mögliche
politische thema das eigentlich in sich
meist sehr komplex ist zu
personalisieren und zu emotionalisieren
es ins bild zu bringen was auch oft gar
nicht so leicht möglich ist und all das
sind wenn sie so wollen unvermeidliche
verzerrungen von realität das heißt wir
müssen abschied nehmen von der
vorstellung es gäbe so was wie eine
objektive berichterstattung
ich habe auch meine lieblings zeitung
ich finde die faz und die welt die
schreiben wirklich wie die wahrheit ist
für mich ich weiß natürlich in als
halbiert gebildeter mensch dass es nicht
so ist dass andere ihre süddeutsche
haben oder ihre anderen sendungen aber
so sehr wir dran hängen dass unsere
eigene meinung immer wieder bestätigt
wird so sehr muss man doch sich klar
machen dass jede welt darstellung eine
art konstruktion ist und dass sie
deshalb niemals die wahrheit bringen
kann lügen als lüge überführen ist eines
ja das ist vollkommen klar wenn jemand
lügt das hat immer kurze beine und kann
entlarvt werden und das in die
journalistin wunderbar dafür
prädestiniert und tun das ja auch aber
viel interessanter sind ja dinge die
einschätzungen ausdrücken oder die
perspektiven ausdrücken wohin geht die
reise wo was soll die politik in zukunft
bringen denken sie an die
flüchtlingsproblematik oder so etwas so
eine einschätzung die flüchtlinge sind
ein geschenk für uns oder sie sind eine
last für uns das ist weder wahrheit noch
lüge
das ist eine politische einschätzung von
ungeheurer bedeutsamkeit und darüber
kann man und muss man streiten
herr bolz hat gerade die wahrheit in
ihrer zeitung gefunden aber sie haben am
anfang lief es schon manchmal da auch
aber auch nicht immer es gibt ja dass
das was ich daran interessant findet das
ist eine der wenigen publikation mit
sehr unterschiedlichen positionen manche
positionen sind auch positionen über die
ich mich ärgert wenn ich das lese aber
ich finde es gut wenn es nicht alles
sozusagen stromlinienförmig in eine
richtung geht so und unterschiedliche
meinung auch tatsächlich ihre raum
finden
und in der tat ist es so dass natürlich
schon die auswahl eines themas
das damit zu tun für systeme ich mich
interessiere und das zusammentragen der
fakten hat natürlich auch etwas damit zu
tun wie ich als journalist oder jemand
anders als journalist irgend eine
bestimmte situation irgend einen
bestimmten sachverhalt einschätzt
also jetzt so zu tun als gäbe es nur die
alleinige wahrheit
das ist glaube ich wirklich falsch vor
allen dingen ist dann die frage wer
entscheidet darüber werden wir ganz kurz
noch mal bei den usa am anfang sie haben
ganz am anfang schon das richtige
stichwort die sozialen netzwerke die
sozialen medien mit eingebracht wäre
trump und auch die debatte über trump
auch in wesel über ihn von seiner
aussagen diskutieren wäre das und er als
politikern präsident überhaupt möglich
ohne die sozialen netzwerke
das kann man sich gar nicht mehr
vorstellen wie das anders wäre ohne die
sozialen netzwerke ich glaube dass das
gesamte politische klima sich was weiß
ich wie im aquarium wenn ihr wasser drin
ist es anders als wir da kein wasser
drin ist völlig anders völlig anders
entwickelt hat und ich glaube man kann
nicht so sich auch nur sehr schwer
vorstellen wie so etwas wäre wenn es das
nicht gäbe also ich glaube dass in der
tat trump auch in der grobheit in der
auftritt und in der artikuliert und wie
er direkt an die wähler oder die
vermeintlichen wlan geht wie er die
medien beschimpft die art wie er wie er
sich artikuliert wie er sich darstellt
eigentlich ein typisches produkt auch
wenn er nicht sozusagen zu den jüngeren
generationen gehört welche aber er hat
das relativ gut kapiert wie man so was
machen muss ob das im endeffekt für ihn
sehr positiv sein wird und ob das seine
wahlchancen noch mal erhöht oder
nächsten andere frage aber insgesamt ist
es ja auch nicht so schlimm wenn die
gesamte bevölkerung über ihre ihre
twitter-accounts oder sonst irgendeine
weise mitdiskutieren kann man es hat
auch jeder das wahlrecht nicht der
blödeste idiot hat heute im wahlrecht
und deswegen kann auch der größte idiot
gewählt werden und deswegen wollen wir
die blöden idioten auch nicht absprechen
dass sie dann mit twitter oder mit
anderen sozialen netzwerken irgendwelche
sachen verbreiten
das ist früher auch schon so gewesen
dass kann bloß konnte bloß damals nicht
jeder nachvollziehen
dort haben die in der kneipe gemacht das
ist jetzt nicht nur die sozialen
netzwerke es waren auch die medien die
ihn groß gemacht haben
je schriller er aufgetreten ist sie
plakat jahre aufgetreten ist
sogar diejenigen medien die gegen ihn
waren
noch ganz genau also er wäre die
alternative gewesen wären sollen
aufgetreten er hat halt ganz bewusst
diese kurzen aufmerksamkeitsspanne in
kurzen musicals die wir mittlerweile
haben genutzt
frei nach der devise spin first
korrekter und das ist ja auch eine
taktik die wir hier bei den
rechtspopulisten
aber ich meine wer über medien verlange
jetzt über trump
ich glaube nicht dass er gewählt worden
ist allein wegen der sozialen medien und
wegen seines auftrittes hat auch sms
gewählt worden weil die alternative für
sehr viele amerikanische wähler nicht
besonders attraktiv gewesen ist kann man
sehen wie man will aber die vereinigten
staaten bestehen eben nicht nur aus der
wall street im osten und silicon valley
im westen sondern müssen da die ganzen
bereiche in der mitte angucken mit den
leuten die irgendwie nicht mehr von
einer arbeit wenn sie überhaupt welche
haben leben können und wie die
infrastruktur ist das sozusagen dieser
dieser begriff america first mit dem man
ja seine erste wahl gewonnen hat die
kann man interpretieren wie deutschland
deutschland über alles man kann es aber
und so ist es im wesentlichen bei uns so
interpretiert worden
man kann es aber auch so interpretieren
jetzt kümmern wir uns erst mal unsere
eigenen sachen und ich glaube diejenigen
die ihn gewählt haben haben das america
first air suchbegriffen nicht sozusagen
die große weltmacht amerika muss wieder
da stehen sondern jetzt lassen wir dafür
sorgen dass das land wieder funktioniert
ob der das jetzt macht ist eine ganz
andere frage aber ich glaube das sind
wesentlicher grund warum gewählt gewählt
worden ist möchte da auch noch sagen
zudem verständnis weil hier sehr viel
über den neuanfang gesprochen haben ist
ich habe die vereinigung von tv merkel
gesehen
die hat auch gestört dem deutschen volke
eine
bundeskanzlerin sein die hat nicht für
europa nicht für serien oder für andere
länder sein sondern für das deutsche
volk das hat natürlich auch der bonner
trump gemacht und so machen dazu dem
medium noch mal durch diese neue medien
wir sind hier drei alte weiße männer und
es sind groß geworden in der alle drei
glaube ich in der analog gesellschaft
und nicht in der digitalen gesellschaft
mit den twitter erreichte 143 millionen
leute die auflage von new york times
also zumindest was weiß ich
die subscription das sind 3 millionen
das ist gar nicht so eine große zeitung
und zu der lügen presse new york times
sein war
wenn eine presse einen anonymen brief
veröffentlicht zitiert dann leute die
sich dann nach denen diese anonyme brief
veröffentlicht worden
distanzieren von diesen aussagen und
wissen sie ich bin in einer eben kein
journalist ich bin der einzige amateur
her in dieser runde aber ich bin immer
unternehmer gewesen und ich bin so
erzogen gewesen dass in einmal
unternehmen ein anonymer brief
angekommen ist das haben wir denn nicht
gelesen man hat ihn zerrissen und
papierkorb geworfen und nun passiert
folgendes diese new york times und
washington post öffentlich in einer
anonymen brief die man überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen kann und zu den medien
noch mal zu der proportion cnn cnbc sind
alle gegen den kampf eingestellt gewesen
dass nur der sender fox und vielleicht
der bei der meistgesehene ist unter den
sendern scheinbar dass man diese
nachrichten die deutschen bekommen und
die anderen nachrichten schätzt man
nicht dann ist das doch der beste beweis
dass die leute die zuschauen diesen
sender auch anschauen weil ich habe mal
hatte einen marktwert der bei den
zuschauern ankommen geben sie uns auch
ein einblick führen sie sich von foxnews
umfassend informiert also reicht ihnen
das als pärchen hin sache antworten
getragen also ersten schaue ich
natürlich alexander also auch
die klingen sender ich eine sache ist
natürlich auf einen glaube ich heute
aber auch bei fox news
wenn es runden gibt da gibt es immer
einen der das konservative den
konservativen blickwinkel vertreten und
bei cnn natürlich alles demokraten und
so weiter und so fort auf der anderen
seite das ist aber das gleiche wie bei
fox da ist immer ein der diese richtung
von den demokraten vertritt und der rest
natürlich mehr konservativ und ich habe
großes problem wenn man hier den
deutschen was populisten als rassisten
als nationalisten und so weiter und so
fort bezeichnet das ist eine eine rolle
mit der sie auch leider auch in den in
den deutschen medien operieren wo sie
praktisch jede argumentation und dass du
sitzt hier ein wissenschaftler sofort
schlagen können wenn sie jemand anderes
rassist der das national ist er ist ein
rechtes populist gut mal gibt es keine
diskussion
bei recht dazu in sachen sex ist so auch
warum ist 666 was hast du ja das kann
ich
zu recht oder zu unrecht die kritik an
donald trump auch von deutschen medien
mit den punkten die herrenberg gerade
genannten na ja das kann man jetzt ja
nicht so pauschal sagen aber natürlich
wenn man sie zum beispiel das sind immer
so die momente die ich jetzt als
journalist oder überhaupt als auch als
zuschauer einfach erschütternd finde
wenn ich sehe wie ein präsident mit all
seiner macht die er hat von oben herab
leute niedermacht dann sind das momente
die ich erschüttern finde und wenn ich
sehe aber ob ich ihn jetzt als rassisten
ich will hat jetzt auch nicht erlebt
dass er in deutschland permanent als
rassist oder als nationalist oder was
hat man sie noch was beispiel hatten sie
noch bezeichnen würde so war es nicht
ich finde er ist jemand der leute
verstört weil man das nicht kennt das
jemand der
aus einer demokratie kommt und in
sozusagen das höchste amt eines eines
staates hat andere leute fertig macht
und natürlich sind dinge wie zum
beispiel das trennen der kinder von
ihren eltern an der mexikanischen mauer
dieser bewerb finden übrigens gemacht
das wahlgesetz punkt klippen und es war
auch obama der ihn gerne das an der
grenze machen wie sie sie argumentieren
auch einseitig sie machen etwas
emotionales die arme kinder und sogar
kinder
es ist ja so es eine übertretung der
amerikanischen grenze ist gesetzeswidrig
so das heißt derjenige der fas wird den
knast das war ja und wenn ein kleines
kind dabei ist könnt ihr doch das gibt
nicht in den knast reinigt humanitäre
maßnahme es ist eine im prinzip eine
humanitäre maßnahmen könnten so
diskussion können wir auf unsere aufgabe
auf die aufgabe der medien ganz noch
zurückholen
unsere aufgabe ist das glaub ich jetzt
hier zu untersuchen ist hertha wirklich
der anwalt derjenigen die ihn gewählt
haben oder ist er vielmehr auf ganz
anderen ebenen unterwegs mit seinen
finanziellen verflechtungen mit seinen
internationalen verpflichtungen ist ja
eigentlich ein oligarch ist er ein
kleptokraten oder ist er wirklich der
anwalt der kleinen leute
was hat er in dieser zeit für die
kleinen leute getan ich glaube das
müssen wir jetzt überprüfen
das ist jetzt bin ich ja tut mir leid
aber ich bin da angefangen worden
er hat für die kleinen leute ganze menge
gemacht er hat eine million leute von
den fünf teams weg gebracht er macht
eine justizreform die den afro
amerikaner zu gute kommen das heißt
leute die ihm im knast sitzen kinder
ausbildung können sich dann behaupten im
leben das hat hat durchgeführt er hat
eine reform musikkorps reform das ist
eine reform praktisch dass in 8900
städte und gemeinden fokussiert worden
die heruntergekommen sind mit 100
milliarden dollar werden diese bereiche
saniert renoviert das sind auch alles
andere bereiche genau die wo eben diese
kleinen leute die politischen
prioritäten leben drin
tut mir leid ich muss irgendwas haben
sie noch war er sich nur abend nicht
schaffen können wir wollen über die
medien und uns selbst sprechen
und deswegen schauen wir einmal weiter
reporter ohne grenzen haben kürzlich
eine neue rangliste veröffentlicht wie
viel pressefreiheit es in den einzelnen
ländern unserer welt gibt die usa sind
demnach abgesagt auf platz 48
das ist hinter taiwan botswana und
rumänien die länder mit der größten
pressefreiheit das sind die
skandinavischen länder und deutschland
hat sich in dem ranking zwar um zwei
plätze verbessert auf platz 13
allerdings nur bei andere länder
zurückgefallen sind sich verschlechtert
haben in der bewertung ist die lage für
journalistinnen und journalisten und die
freie presse in deutschland nämlich auch
schlechter geworden anfeindungen gegen
journalisten in deutschland lügen presse
rufe und gewalt eine große
vertrauenskrise
das sind aber auch wirklich gewalttätige
übergriffe bis hin zum verletzungen
das heißt das klima hat sich da extrem
verschärft auch wenn immerhin 44 prozent
der deutschen den medien grundsätzlich
vertrauen herrscht laut einer aktuellen
studie eine starke polarisierung eine
minderheit sei laut und arbeite gegen
medien
es geht nämlich darum das demokratische
system zu zerschießen
die wollen keine demokratie die wollen
keine freie meinungsäußerung von allen
seiten
und an der stelle sind wir natürlich die
richtigen gegner und manchmal
verursacher einer krise der fall
reduziert die fälschungen des
preisgekrönten spiegel reporters
beschäftigen die branche noch immer
steht die glaubwürdigkeit infrage
die gesellschaftliche haltung ändert
sich das wird anders eingefordert von
uns dass wir auch erklären was wir tun
und dass wir auch mal fehler einräumen
das gehört auch dazu das haben wir in
der vergangenheit nicht getan
in der silvesternacht 2015 belästigen in
köln nordafrikanische männer hunderte
frauen die medien hieß es danach hätten
aus angst vor der wahrheit zu lange
geschwiegen aufklärung kam erst nach
langer zeit
erstens die medien sind selbstkritisch
dran gegangen und haben auch über ihre
fehler berichtet zweitens der staat die
politik haben konsequenzen gezogen der
mensch der dafür verantwortlich war ist
nicht mehr im dienst und das ist auch
gut so
die deutschen parteien wollen ihre
eigene medien öffentlichkeit schaffen
die kanzlerin macht es vor und die afg
will nachrichten ungefiltert ans
publikum bringen und annegret kramp
karrenbauer lobt ihre eigene pr
maschinerie cdu live stream ohne
journalisten
zitat wir waren herr über die bilder wir
haben die nachrichten selbst produziert
frau sei sie waren lange im ausland
haben aus ägypten aus russland aus der
ukraine berichtet und im letzten jahr
erst wieder zurückgekommen nach
deutschland waren sie da überrascht von
der lügen presse debatte hier bei uns in
deutschland
nein das ist ja etwas was mir die ganzen
jahre eigentlich begegnet ist in
sozialen medien in briefen in
zuschriften in e mails wurde ich ja
immer wieder als lügen presse
angeprangert der ganze konflikt hat sich
ja eigentlich wenn man jetzt
zurückblickt wie sich ukraine russland
konflikt entwickelt hat dann ist das ja
sozusagen der der knall gewesen der
urknall gewesen der das ganze ins rollen
gebracht hat also insofern also vor dem
ganzen thema haben flüchtlinge migration
noch damals die zeit
naja sie auch berichtet haben aus der
ukraine und in russland das wollen wir
auch darüber sprechen wie sie das erlebt
haben im beitrag haben wir eben kurz
noch von einer studie gehört das war
eine repräsentative befragung der
mainzer johannes gutenberg-universität
demnach sind die vertrauenswerte für
printmedien oder auch die
öffentlich-rechtlichen sender eigentlich
sehr gut relativ gut mit einer deutlich
mehrheit über 60 prozent der menschen
die den vertrauen schaut man aber auf
einzelne themen zum beispiel
über den islam oder kriminalität von
flüchtlingen
da ist auf einmal das vertrauen sehr
gering da glauben nur 20 bis 25 prozent
der menschen was in diesen artikeln oder
in den beiträgen zu sehen zu lesen ist
deswegen wir haben schon gehört gab ein
thema auch vor flüchtlinge migration
aber ist auch das thema nochmal auslöser
oder weiterer schub gewesen für das
misstrauen vieler menschen
ja ich glaube das war sogar einer der
ganz wesentlichen punkte wie das was
hier auch angesprochen worden ist die
die silvester krawalle darf in köln auf
der domplatte über die ist nicht sofort
und so umfassend berichtet worden wie
man das eigentlich normalerweise hätte
erwarten können
ich kann mich an diese vorgänge sehr
genau erinnern ich war selbst überrascht
ich war zu der zeit nebenbei auch noch
mal chefredakteur der welt und der welt
am sonntag und an diesen in dieser woche
und ich kann mich sogar erinnern dass es
erhebliche zweifel auch bei uns in der
redaktion gab ob das wirklich so
gravierend sei und natürlich haben immer
viele leute jetzt nicht nicht nur
wesentlich über uns aber insgesamt so
die meinung gehabt ja wenn man darüber
zu viel berichtet dann würde man ja
sozusagen die bevölkerung anstacheln
gegen die asylbewerber gegen die
flüchtlinge die kommen ich glaube da ist
viel rücksicht genommen worden und damit
hat man auch eine ganze menge
glaubwürdigkeit verspielt glaube das ist
in der tat seit in der auch die bild
damals vom vom springer-verlag auch noch
rapid i swear kam auf helfer verteilt
hat ja in der tat ist gab ja auch sehr
unterschiedliche positionen und ich muss
sagen ich war bin ja nur lange genug in
dem geschäft und habe mich lange genug
damit beschäftigt auch mit diesen themen
so dass ich da weniger rücksichtsvoll
gewesen bin und ich war der meinung dass
man über das was ist auch berichten
sollte und nicht zu viel von dem
wunschdenken was man hat darüber wie die
gesellschaft zu sein hat und wie sie
sein sollte und wie menschen denken
sollten nicht zu sehr in den vordergrund
stellt sondern genau über das berichtet
was tatsächlich passiert denn in
wirklichkeit bricht sich das natürlich
doch irgendwann die bahn und dann merken
haben die leute das gefühl sie werden
nicht richtig unterrichtet und ich
glaube aus dieser zeit kann man eine
ganze menge lernen
frau becker die silvesternacht in der
vor allem frauen angegriffen wurden
übergriffe stattgefunden haben hätte man
da anders mehr schneller darüber
berichten sollen man hätte vielleicht
schneller darüber berichten können aber
ich glaube ein einzelnes ereignis dafür
verantwortlich zu machen dass vielleicht
auch das vertrauen in medien sinkt das
halte ich für ein bisschen zu kurz
gegriffen wenn man sich die zum beispiel
die mainzer studie zu vertrauen in
medien anschaut dann sehen wir natürlich
einen anstieg des misstrauens in medien
und was menschen da sagen ist dass sie
sich zum einen nicht repräsentiert
fühlen also sie fühlen sich nicht
angesprochen von journalistinnen und
journalisten und sie beschreiben sie
nehmen ihren alltag anders wahr als sie
ihn in den medien wieder finden und das
ist eigentlich ein plädoyer dafür wenn
wir über pressefreiheit sprechen für
medienvielfalt für starke lokalmedien
für starke regionalmedien und für
diversität in den medien weil was ich
hier widerspiegelt ist das vielleicht
auch nicht immer redaktionen soll den
nerv treffen können was ihre leserinnen
und leser bewegt dass sie themen
verpassen man kann natürlich nicht alles
darstellen aber wenn man eine
entfremdung stattfindet
dann kann es hinweis darauf sein dass
man themen verpasst und eben nicht mehr
so nah am leser ist und wenn leserinnen
und leser daneben auch noch sagen sowie
finden unseren alltag da gar nicht
wieder dann muss man auch noch mal
fragen warum und wir haben zum beispiel
bei regionalmedien gesehen dass gerade
viel in hauptstadtbüros investiert wird
dh die berichterstattung über
bundespolitik wird verstärkt und
vielleicht könnte es ja eine bessere
idee seien wieder in starker
lokalredaktionen zu investieren um zu
gucken was passiert da eigentlich vor
ort weil da ist natürlich den letzten
jahren unheimlich viel abgebaut worden
die lokalberichterstattung wird dünner
und das da dann auch vertrauen in medien
schwindet das finde ich nachvollziehbar
da sich die lokalen zeitungen in den
kleineren städten spielen noch eine
gewaltige rolle
und insofern das internet hat ja auch
nicht nur negative aspekte sondern auch
sehr positive die darin bestehen wenn
die einen das eine verschlafen dann
findet man irgendein video oder
irgendeine mitteilung im internet und
dann merken die redakteure auch dass sie
das verpennt haben aber ich habe
eine äusserung gehört dass das
misstrauen gegenüber die medien den
medien in irgendeiner weise korreliert
wäre mit zu geringer lokale
berichterstattung
dieses argument ist mir vollkommen neue
habe ich noch niemals gehört das mag
alles stimmt was ich sagen dass es
defizite gibt aber das begründet nicht
dieses fundamentale misstrauen in diesen
entscheidenden fragen die sie gerade
angesprochen habe es geht ja nicht um
ein prinzipielles desinteresse an
klassischen medien sondern es geht darum
dass in den großen fragen den großen
politischen den heißen themen die leute
das gefühl haben betrogen zu werden
sie werden allerdings nicht betrogen
durch eine lügen presse das ist einfach
unsinn das war immer uns in dieser
vorwurf eines bleibt es auch religiös
ist ein sonderfall sondern ist der
andere vorwurf der auch mal aufgekommen
ist dann rücken presse da ist was dran
also es wie meinen sie das bestanden
diese lücke nun als das heißt ganz
einfach man weiß dass etwas passiert ist
man bringt es aber nicht als nachricht
aus wie sie wieder heraus richtig gesagt
hat rücksicht auf die bürger die das
offenbar nicht verkraften können
und das ist glaube ich das wirklich
gefährliche dass viele journalisten das
gefühl haben sie haben einen wissen sie
haben informationen die man den menschen
da draußen im lande nicht zumuten kann
weil sie nicht in der lage sind
erwachsen darauf zu reagieren
als er eben nicht zu einer eigenen marke
zu sehen sie einer möglichen also das
finde ich schwierig muss muss diesmal
alles zusammenpassen
ich bin nicht so ganz sicher ob wirklich
menschen deswegen die glaubwürdigkeit
nicht sehen weil sie ihren alltag nicht
widergespiegelt sehen sondern ich habe
den also die gibt ja immer diesen satz
gefühlte wahrheit ist auch eine wahrheit
und gerade in diesem ganzen thema
kriminalität und flüchtlinge ist sehr
viel gefühlte wahrheit im spiel und das
sind sehr viele menschen die sagen da
ist jedes passiert oder folgendes und
die presse hat nicht darüber berichtet
dann ist gar nichts passiert also da ist
da ist soviel wabern des unklares das
ist für die medien für journalisten auch
etwas schwierig ist darauf einzugehen
also ich habe das gefühl dass es gibt
eine große erwartungshaltung auf dinge
einzugehen dies aber teilweise gar nicht
gibt so das finde ich erstmal
problematisch mit der lücken presse das
finde ich auch schwierig weil das würde
ja das klingt so ein bisschen für mich
wie als würden in den redaktionsstuben
so art weiß ich nicht journalisten
sitzen die dem volk was zumuten wollen
oder nichts zumal nicht wollen und wir
dann sachen sozusagen unterdrücken das
habe ich so auch noch nicht wahr
genommen also kann es jetzt natürlich
nur aus meinem redaktionsalltag das kann
ich nicht behaupten
in der tat kann man sich zum beispiel
fragen warum hat man nicht in köln muss
ja anscheinend auf der domplatte immer
wieder zu diesen an tanz versuchen oder
oder handtaschenraub oder sonst
irgendwas kamen nicht vorher darüber
berichtet dass es anscheinend ein
kriminalitätsproblem mit man skeptisch
für vor allem nordafrikaner gab die da
irgendwie ihr unwesen treiben da ich
mich oft schon gefragt hätten wir
darüber berichtet so jetzt hätte ich als
bundesweites magazin wahrscheinlich
nicht über kriminalität auf der kölner
domplatte weil das wäre mir jetzt zu
regional gewesen aber wenn man gemerkt
hatte ok das kommt sehr häufig vor
ja hätte man wahrscheinlich darüber
berichtet dass jetzt zum beispiel diese
kölner silvesternacht superheld wurde
war glaube ich auch weil journalisten in
diesem moment man daher nichtig sind
auch die kamen wir nach einem silvester
urlaub so und das war ja vollkommen
unklare nachrichtenlage also man hatte
ja auch selbst die ganz kurz nur ich
weiß schon es gab ja ganz viel man darf
nicht vergessen dass auch die auch die
offiziellen pressekonferenzen ja geprägt
waren von desinformation so und dass die
weiß noch wie wir da alle saßen und
versucht haben uns wenn man nicht in
köln vor ort war wo sich ein bild zu
machen nicht warum also jetzt einfach
überhaupt nur ein bild zu machen und zu
sagen hey was ist denn da passiert man
muss ja dinge auch erst einmal begreifen
bevor man schon raus geht ich habe mich
sehr war sehr erstaunt wie so mancher
journalist bereits dienstag morgens eine
komplette analyse machen konnte dass es
an den muslimischen falsch erzogen
männer liegen kann wo ich dachte ja ja
das war toll ich weiß das alles noch
nicht also die ich würde nie so ich
würde nie sagen dass journalisten
absichtlich sachen zurückhaltend um
um die bevölkerung also
wie sie war das wie der dmi sehr satz
ich dinge meint was hat er was damit zu
tun dass journalisten sehr häufig und
ich finde zu häufig ein eigenes
sendungsbewusstsein haben und dass ein
stück in den vordergrund stellen und ich
kann mich erinnern an genau diese tage
und das ist da ist die domplatte ein
beispiel es gibt verschiedene andere
beispiele dafür dass leute das nicht
wahrhaben wollen denn sie dürfen nicht
vergessen das war die zeit in der ihm
tatsächlich noch dieses werk kempowskis
euphorie war und da passte das irgendwie
nicht ins bild
und ich kann mich erst mal zu ende sein
es passt der folge ist nicht ins bild
und ich bringe das mal auf ein zitat wir
haben eine heftige diskussion darüber
geführt und da wurde gesagt ja das waren
ja gar keine flüchtlinge im eigentlichen
sinne
das heißt es passte sozusagen nicht ins
konzept und ich glaube das spielt eine
gewaltige rolle ich sage ihnen anderes
zitat als an dem abend an dem ihr an
dies ambri mit dem bus in die
menschenmenge reingefahren ist damit
verschiedene besucher sofort in die
redaktion
und ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen von
wem aber dann hat einer gesagt hoff als
es noch nicht klar wer das gewesen ist
da hatte gesagt hoffentlich war es um
besoffener pole weil er gedacht hat um
gottes willen was für eine diskussion
werden wir haben wenn sich herausstellt
dass es ein asylbewerber ist das heißt
wir sind ihr sehr 46 begriffe und
gedacht oder hat er an
gesellschaftlichen streit bis hand sein
die dabei hoffentlich ist es kein
flüchtling gewesen weil wir dann eine
solche diskussion plötzlich haben
diese gedanken werden der gedanke der
behälter gesteht eingestanden hat den
der hoffnung zu haben nicht aber noch
mal was anderes ob man kann objektiv
berichten
als beispiel dafür was in den köpfen
vorsichtig die sagen hoffentlich ist es
nicht so hier sind aber auch in zeiten
in denen natürlich jegliche also alles
was passiert natürlich sofort
instrumentalisiert wird also ich würde
selbst ein brand in rotterdam wird
natürlich sofort dafür benutzt um gegen
muslime zu also das heißt es dass man so
einen gedanken den kopf schießt
ähnliches ist auf dieses ereignis
zurückzuschauen und ich denke das
sollten wir immer wieder tun und immer
wieder nochmal uns analysieren so sehr
müssen wir uns auch der tatsache bewusst
werden dass wir die jahre danach über
korrigiert haben und zwar in der
hoffnung dass wir dann endlich von denen
die uns als links bezeichnen endlich
quasi verstanden werden dass uns wieder
vertraut was ist passiert
du hast du das dann ja ein
sondertraining gesetzen oder ständer
journalismus sozusagen sich bahn bricht
also dass man nur noch sagt okay der
sagt das und die sagt dass und damit
haben wir sozusagen die wahrheit
abgebildet also es ist eine über
vorsicht jetzt entstanden und wir nehmen
jetzt auch nicht mehr richtig war das
ist ja auch rechte
kommunikationsstrategien gibt die
natürlich da mit uns versuchen ihre
schlagzeilen da durchgesetzt das heißt
weniger bewertung einordnung oder nennen
wir müssen uns einfach gewahr werden das
ist verschieden aber was sie mit uns
spielen genau was passiert ist in den
letzten drei vier jahren die medien
haben sich ja an vielen stellen
verändert auch wie wir mit den fehlern
umgehen von faktenchecks bis anderen
arten dafür sich in die andere richtung
ausschlagen und das will ich da nein
sagen und ihre befürchtung die andere
richtung wäre dass wir einfach zu viele
talkshows haben die nein nein nein ich
verschiedene meinungen das ist ja unsere
aufgabe dass wir diese meinungen
wahrnehmen und deswegen mit diesen
menschen gibt solche meinungen haben ins
gespräch kommen nur wo hört das auf dann
kommen wir auch mit denen ins gespräch
die das grundgesetz wurde die
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
oder eigentlich unsere arbeitsgrundlage
die pressefreiheit abschaffen wollen wie
gehen wir damit um und ich glaube das
ist genau der spagat in dem wir uns
bewegen also es wurde direkt nach köln
beispielsweise könntest du wochenlange
den zeitungen unmengen von kriminalitäts
fällen von menschen die nicht deutsch
waren oder die als nicht deutsch
bezeichnet worden in der es wirklich ist
schwankend wirklich so auf die andere
doch was ist den letzten versuch
objektiver berichterstattung ist ja auch
nicht ob ich ist das ein objektiv ist
die frage versuch sage ich dann versucht
zu berichten was ist heißt es nicht so
schön über ihre früheren zusagen was ist
weil das nicht die fordert dass ich sage
dass das wirklich interessante ist dass
dieser satz von urlaub augstein sagen
was ist ist dann am zusammenhang der
etwas damit zu tun hat
dass er sagte journalisten sollten sich
nicht so wichtig nehmen dass sich die
idee nicht er hat gesagt und da aus
diesem zusammenhang stammt ja auch das
wort mit dem sturmgeschütz der
demokratie
das hat er ironisch gemeint er hat
gesagt dass manche von uns dachten wir
sind dass das selbsternannte
sturmgeschütz der demokratie
und da waren wir weniger einflussreich
als zu dem zeitpunkt wie jetzt damals
als nämlich nach der spiegel-affäre wo
man uns gleichzeitig zum trocknen auf
dem boden aufgehängt hat da sind wir
einflussreich gewesen und er hat gesagt
die aufgabe des journalisten besteht
nicht darin regierung oder koalition zu
promoten oder zu promovieren hat er
gesagt in diesem satz sondern der
einfluss des journalismus besteht darin
dass man sagt was ist setzen wir auch
nicht aber das ist schon mal sehr viel
objektivität bei der berichterstattung
über sexualisierte gewalt ins spiel
gebracht haben weil wenn wir
objektivität hätten oder angemessen über
sexualisierte gewalt bericht erstatten
würden dann hätten wir jeden tag die
zeitung voll und hätten der einblick in
die täter strukturen und es gibt eine
sogen eine rechte diskurs strategie
nennt sich länder nationalismus das
heißt das von rechten in den vordergrund
gestellt wird da wird aufgemacht wir
sind ein modernes land wir sind für
frauenrechte und nur die migranten oder
die muslime stellen frauenrechte in
frage das heißt rechte diskurse springen
auf fälle auf wenn vielleicht migranten
die täter waren und machen die groß und
vereinnahmen für minister für haltungen
an diesem punkt während sie dann aber
zum beispiel gegen die istanbul
konvention stimmen die frauen besser
gegen sexualisierte gewalt schützen
wollen soll oder geschlechterforschung
in frage stellen und da hat man eine
tatsächliche verzerrung wenn wir über
sexualisierte gewalt sprechen objektiv
dann ist das ein sehr weites feld mit
sehr sehr vielen deutschen tätern und
einer wachsenden zahl von auch
migrantischen tätern aber die
überwiegende zahl der täter ist aktuell
deutsch und wir dürfen nicht so tun als
wäre sexualisierte gewalt in deutschland
ein migrant das problem das ist es nicht
ich würde gerne hier an die rotunde eine
frage stellen
und zwar wie ist das mit der
verantwortung der journalisten
politische verantwortung der
journalisten und da habe ich ein
konkretes fall und zwar des höchsten
würdenträger in deutschland das
ehemaligen bundespräsidenten in
deutschland wir wissen warum wir reden
diese bundespräsident hat ein streit mit
einem journalisten gehabt und daraus ist
eine welle entstanden wo sämtliche
medien presse auf diesen
bundespräsidenten in höchsten träger des
amtes hier in deutschland an geprügelt
hat man hat die man aus dem amt gejagt
seine ehe ist kaputt gegangen und man
hat ihn fertig wir machen dort ihre
frage ich denke an wulff natürlich
juristisch ist es geklärt worden und da
ist natürlich eine parallele jetzt zum
donald trump mit müller auch
investigation wo man juristisch geklärt
hat der mann hat nichts gemacht und den
hat man aus dem amt gejagt man hat ihn
fertig gemacht das haben journalisten
gemacht presse und media und was ist
passiert gar nicht wo ist die
verantwortung der journalisten für
solche sachen und das gleiche ist jetzt
wie müller report us rausgekommen ist
dreimal 0 0 nun gar nichts passiert war
gar nicht so gut ist sehr wichtig und
sehr unterschiedliche einschätzung dazu
aber natürlich ist es so dass jemand der
in einer sehr hohen position ist muss
damit leben dass das was sozusagen als
verdachtsmoment gegen den auftritt dass
das sehr sorgfältig untersucht wird sehr
groß untersucht wird und sehr aufwendig
untersucht wird
und ja sorgfältig und wirklich aufwändig
und damit natürlich auch eine große
öffentlichkeit manchmal löst ist das
risiko das sie haben wenn sie in der
leiten und position sind
ich bin in der tat der meinung dass bei
wulff ein bisschen übertrieben worden
dass insgesamt vielleicht hat das auch
was damit zu tun dass in der zeit sonst
nichts passierte ich möchte den begriff
techno es noch mal in die runde bringen
fake news kommen oft so schnell in den
umlauf fortschritt kann man die
überhaupt anfangen kann
wieder zurückholen es bleibt doch immer
bleibt immer ein eindruck von einer
behauptung in den raum geworfen wird
oder fällt
es ist ein schwieriger begriff finde ich
weil wir auch eben schon über fakten
geredet haben also jahren heißt es immer
als journalist weil das ist irgendwie
das handwerkszeug aus wir haben ja wir
müssen fakten berichten derweil sie
haben ja auch gerade schon gesagt
letztendlich kommt es ja gar nicht so
sehr auf die fakten an sondern um die
auf die bewertung von fakten also wenn
man jetzt was wir hier damals ukraine
nimmt ja diese diese uhr den urknall
so hatten wir erst mal stimmt genau ist
der faktor russland hat die krim
eingenommen
es war was die krim bürgerwehr die das
gemacht hätte so russische sollte denn
du das sagst du weißt du sagen aber
schon ein teil ja aber die wollten die
bevölkerung wollte ja da gab es auch in
der verhandlung die wollten doch gerne
zu russland so ist schon wieder der
bewertung
völkerrechtlich ist es klar aber schon
das wird ihr sozusagen entgegen gehalten
und als nicht objektive oder gesteuerte
oder einseitige berichterstattung unter
stellten sie die tiere in eine andere
richtung nämlich in die in die frage ob
tatsächlich doch genau und fake news
wird immer so also was sind denn fake
news jetzt haben wir zum beispiel gerade
diese ganze diskussion über die
polizeiliche kriminalitätsstatistik
seehofer sagt wir sind eines der
sichersten länder sagte er unser
innenministers kann man noch einen
seehofer glauben oder nicht
genauso und dann kommt die afg und sagt
ja also der innenminister liegt weil die
leute haben eine ganz andere wahrnehmung
und wenn man die zahlen liest dann kommt
da was ganz anderes raus ja was sie denn
jetzt die fake news erschließen problem
des journalismus erinnerung das sehr
spannend bewertung ist wirklich
unendlich wichtig nämlich für die
politik die politik besteht im
wesentlichen aus bewertungen von fakten
oder auch vielleicht von von fantasien
und von projektionen aber der
journalismus sollte das gerade nicht tun
meines erachtens sollte der journalismus
bewertungen und informationen trennen er
sollte berichte und meinungen trennen
sie können gerne ihre kommentare machen
im tages treten und so weiter aber das
sollte irgendwie schritt wissen sie so
wie früher in den alten zeitungen zu
einem anstrich was drüber steht das sind
die informationen was drunter steht ist
die meinung von irgendwelchen
redakteuren und das problem das wir
haben vor allen dingen in öffentlich
rechtlichen system
ist das immer häufiger informationen und
themen mit ganz bestimmten meinungen
verschmolzen werden
das ist das gefährliche so dass man als
rezipient als leser als zuschauer das
gefühl hat zu diesem thema darfst du
überhaupt nur noch diese meinung haben
es ist nicht unser problem das wir
wahnsinnige meinungsvielfalt hätten und
dass man da steuern müsste sondern unser
problem ist dass sich viele leute bei
vielen themen gar nicht mehr trauen eine
alternative meinung zu äußern bei bei
meinung auch in kommentaren ist es ja
auch nicht immer einfach die man kriegt
viel gegenwind sie haben vorrechte
beitrages den kommentaren zwar auch viel
zuspruch bekommen aber auch mehrmals zum
großen geschützturm wie haben sie das
stimmt allerdings da ist es ja klar es
ist ein kommentar da kann es leute sagen
den finde ich dufte
dann schreiben sie halt oder regen sich
auch schon gut aber was sie ja meinen
ist ja eher in normalen berichten wenn
man da jetzt eben sagen wir mal
beispielsweise war jetzt nun gerade erst
diese diese frage ist jetzt ein sicheres
lade bericht ist klassisch
pressekonferenz herr seehofer hast du
der tagesschau seehofer sagt alles super
hier die kriminalitätsstatistik ist in
sämtlichen punkten runtergegangen und
dem einen nicht aber insgesamt sind wir
in sicheres land
ist das jetzt ein bericht wenn du den so
max der mit einer meinung gefärbt ist ja
die politik politiker sollen meinungen
und kommentare schreiben und sagen ja er
sagt ist ein sicheres land sich
irgendwie anders verglichen mit was weiß
ich alles noch machen kommentar weil sie
ja sagt er würde alles vermischt wird
machst du jetzt einen eintrag dann
kommen natürlich ganz viele leute sagen
da ist alles vermischt weil man kann sie
auch ganz anders sehen nicht deshalb
weil die politiker ihre meinung äußern
lassen ist alles vermischt sondern weil
in den darstellungen von irgendwelchen
politischen problemen information und
meinung sich immer mehr verschmelzen
dass sie immer mehr ineinander übergehen
so dass sie zu bestimmten nehmen wir
doch mal ein krasses beispiel werden mit
trump ja zurecht angefangen
sie hätten auch noch putin bringen
können oder erdogan oder so irgendwelche
figuren zu diesen figuren kann man
zumindest bei uns in deutschland nur
noch eine meinung haben wenn sie eine
andere meinung zu trump hätten als die
die wenn man zu flächendeckend in allen
medien verbreitet wird bei uns
sind sie ein outlaw in sie ein
außenseiter und sie könnten sich gar
nicht äußern
das finde ich zu beurteilen mit
positiven kommentar zu trump in
irgendeinem medium in deutschland gehört
das ist natürlich der wenn dubai trump
darüber diskutiert wie er meinetwegen
sozialisten fertig macht dann ist es
relativ schwierig dazu eine positive
meinung oder wenn natürlich die deutsche
wirtschaft angst hat davor dass
irgendwelche zölle gemacht werden
dann wirst du das so berichten ja gut
aber da muss man verschiedene
verschiedene seiten münchen
wissen sie ich sie sind hier wir sind
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk das
heißt die leute bezahlen müssen bezahlen
gebühren dh sie kaufen nachrichten und
wenn ich etwas kaufe möchte ich eine
gute ware wird nein
doch plötzlich aus dem nächsten
nachrichten einigen kleinen sieg und
nicht mehr halten und hat mir die welt
in schwarz weißen farben erklären und
nicht anders und die welt weiß sie dass
die welt grau ist und zwar in
verschiedenen tönen dann ärgert mich das
und diese branchen von von donald trump
wissen sie im spiegel gab es eine
titelseite da war erdogan da war putin
unter war der nordkoreanische führer und
der donald trump donnert hat niemand
vergiftet es gibt zwar kann sie keine
konzentrations camps in in usa und er
hat keine journalisten im knast gesetzt
und warum ist er jetzt warum ist jetzt
drei diktatoren als ein diktator oder im
spiegel im sommer der so landrat
eingewickelt in eine magische frage mit
einem hitlergruß was soll das das ist
ein niveau von dem mann den ich sehr
sehr sachlichen und und türkischen
medien die die frau merkel
es ist nie vorbei aber er ist nicht nur
der titel wurde sehr sehr sehr kritisch
gesehen
frankes worden die leute haben das
gefühl so kleinemas erkennt dass wir
werden wieder anschluss nur noch
zusammensitzen und partys noch
ausdiskutieren
ich möchte noch einmal dahin schon mal
angesprochen wurden sie haben einige
jahre als auslandskorrespondentin vor
allem in der zeit als über die aus der
ukraine berichtet haben gesprochen
sie haben in der zeit ziemlich heftige
kritik bis hin zu hass und drohungen
erleben vor allem auch über die sozialen
netzwerke und es gab auch ein punkt an
dem sie überlegt haben können sie das so
dann noch weitermachen
das heißt die kritik war so heftig und
der hass dass das für sie auch fast eine
grenze gehabt hätte ja das war mein
zweiter einsatz als
auslandskorrespondentin und ich habe
einfach gemerkt
für mich war es neu dass auf berichte
die menschenrechtsvergehen
thematisierten ein so heftiger gegenwind
von zuschauern plötzlich uns als
korrespondent in moskau und da sieht man
alle korrespondenten in moskau betroffen
nicht nur ich dass uns so ein heftiger
gegenwind entgegen gekommen ist dass da
sind bei mir die alarmlampen angegangen
was passiert da gerade wie so weckt ein
bericht über menschenrechte so viel
abwehrreaktionen
wieso wird das ganze in falsche
analogien runtergebrochen auch was die
russen machen ist ja nicht so schlimm
wenn sie das jetzt mit den amerikanern
vergleichen dann sieht das jetzt mit dem
vergleichen und dem also was hat sich da
in deutschland genau entwickelt das war
die eine entwicklung die ich
festgestellt habe die zweite mann
beginnt wenn man so heftig angegriffen
wird beginnt man die reaktion der trolle
im kopf zu antizipieren und da konnte
ich durchaus bei mir feststellen dass
ich gelegentlich am rande der
selbstzensur war oder einfach versucht
habe ein bisschen stiller zu werden ein
bisschen unangreifbarer zu werden
auch das wird mich sehr sehr
verunsichert und ich habe mich gefragt
wo bewege ich mich da eigentlich
sie haben ja die trolle erwähnt von wem
diese kritik also wann das zuschauer
waren dass man das gesteuerte ganz
unterschiedliche milieus es waren
zuschauer mit denen ich dann auch einen
regen briefwechsel hatte das war ein
richtiger authentischer personen das
waren aber auch gesteuerte bots wie ich
dann im nachhinein festgestellt habe die
an ganz vielen stellen im netz in den
sozialen medien ihre spuren und ihre
kommentare hinterlassen hatten und die
teilweise auch für kommerzielle zwecke
eingesetzt wurden also das ist mir immer
wieder aufgefallen aber es gab natürlich
auch viel zuspruch das muss man auch
noch sagen also es gab wirklich sehr
viele briefe die uns gestärkt haben so
weiter zu machen wie wir berichten und
ich muss noch mal auf sie zurückkommen
habe ich gesagt haben es gibt ein
meinungsbild dass ich da festgesetzt hat
ich muss ihnen widersprechen wenn sie
sich die gesamte die gesamten programme
der ard anschauen in den vergangenen
jahren da werden sie feststellen dass es
durchaus in den magazinen auch berichte
gegeben hat die sich in die klemme logik
rhein gefunden haben oder zum beispiel
bei titel thesen temperamente wieder
eine ganz andere linie gefahren sind
oder in den comedy und kabarett
programmen von ard und zdf
also ich muss sehen da widersprechen es
ist nicht eine linie gewesen und auch
wir korrespondenten haben über
diejenigen berichtet die putin gut
finden das system gut finden aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen
was ich interessant finde hier sitzen
runde mehrere die aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen persönlich
auch kritisiert angefeindet wurden
wir haben über ihren fall gerade
gesprochen und damit klarkommen müssen
in der arbeit
herr bolz zu ihnen gibt es auch stimmen
von leuten die sagen sie haben als
wissenschaftler viele jahre analysiert
meinung vertreten und jetzt aber doch
ziemlich eine linie bis hin zu manchen
die sagen es ins populistische hinein
oder heraus manche sagen sie waren doch
früher ein linker sie waren beim spiegel
und jetzt bei springer kann wirklich
überrascht wie gehen sie damit dann auch
ich halte ich habe meine position nicht
wesentlich geändert was ich ihn wirklich
sagen also ich wenn ich gefragt werde
wie kann das sein dann sage ich jetzt
immer scherzhaft das hätte sich auch
niemand vorstellen können dass der
springer verlag mann rudi dutschke
straße liegt wenn auch nicht mehr da mit
dem haupteingang
ich glaube dass insgesamt hat sich das
hat sich die stimmung sozusagen in der
bevölkerung ein stück verändert und in
den medien ein stück verändert der
spiegel wird heute noch dafür kritisiert
dass er mal ein titel gemacht hat den
ich veranlasst habe der windkraft waren
stehe ich heute noch zu jeder zeit
obwohl es nicht geschrieben habe wir
haben über mangelnde integration mal ein
titel gemacht mit der zeile gefährlich
fremd das heißt die position die ich
damals hatte und zwar dadurch weil ich
aber die realität so ein geschätzter wie
ich sie eingeschätzt habe hat sich nicht
so wahnsinnig viel verändert und ich
will ihnen sagen ich finde bei all dem
was wir hier diskutieren
das ist wie über das internet und jeder
kann jetzt an wie seinen unsinn da zum
besten geben es hat auch gewaltige
vorteile
ich sage ihnen was ich noch nie erlebt
habe früher war das was ich heute erlebe
welchen die geschichte schreibt einen
kommentar schreiben
und der wird bei welt online herr
ausgegeben und zwar hinter dem
pluszeichen das heißt die leute müssen
dafür bezahlen wir haben uns 100.000
abonnenten die das die das abonnieren
das heißt es ist ein begrenzter
personenkreis und wieviel reaktionen sie
darauf kriegen wie viele unglaublich
kluge leserkommentare sie kriegen also
ich hab neulich so eine geschichte
gemacht da hab ich irgendwie 850
leserbriefe dazu gekriegt und ich habe
sie ich sage ihnen ich habe sie alle
durchgelesen und sie wundern sich was
für gute kluge leute das sind die zum
teil wirklich mindestens genauso gut
schreiben wir die journalistin über uns
schreiben also wirklich richtig gute
leute und das finde ich außerordentlich
positiv dass man so man kann dann auch
so eine chat gruppe machen setzt man
sich mal hin und korrespondiert mit den
leuten direkt live und das finde ich in
meiner leben meiner karriere als
journalist habe ich das noch nicht
erlebt dass man mit den lesern in einem
so engen und direkten kontakt stehen
kann und finde ich wirklich also auch
heute auch ein sehr spannender sich
gebracht haben nämlich die frage habe
ich mich geändert oder nicht ich habe
einen ähnlichen eindruck wie sie ich
habe eigentlich immer noch dieselben
auffassung wie vor 20 jahren das mag ja
ein sprecher sein dass man sich nicht
wort bildet aber ich habe eigentlich
auffassung wie vor 20 jahren und zwar
ziemlich ähnlich zu diesen fragen die so
aufregend sind wie die damals der
innenminister hatte
von der spd früher grüne also positionen
die damals ganz selbstverständlich waren
wenn man die heute noch vertritt ist man
rechtspopulist und das ist das lustige
an der ganzen sache es hat sich in
unserem öffentlichen diskurs enorm viel
verändert das hat sich gedreht und sie
können sehr sehr viele positionen die
noch vor 20 jahren wenn sie es wollen
flächendeckend verbreitet waren in der
nicht nur in der repräsentativen
öffentlichkeit sondern auch in der
bevölkerung
die können sie heute gar nicht mehr
artikulieren ohne dieses label zu
bekommen und rechtspopulisten
das hat eine gewisse ähnlichkeit mit dem
also ich kann mich entsinnen ich habe
immer so gedacht ich bin so eine art
sagen ein nonkonformist recht also wenn
wenn ich der meinung bin dass die
mehrheit der bevölkerung oder des
staates und der bevölkerung wenn die
mehrheit irgendwie eine auffassung ist
dann bin ich immer schon aus prinzip
dagegen
das ist bei mir auch heute noch so
früher hieß es dann wenn sie die
kapitalismus kritisiert haben dann geh
doch nach drüben in die ddr
und so ähnlich ist das heute ob es
umgekehrt wir schauen noch auf einen
weiteren punkt wenn wir über bedrohte
pressefreiheit sprechen dann denk mir
aktuell vor allem an die türkei oder
russland beispielsweise in der türkei
sitzen allein im moment wohl mehr als
150 journalisten im gefängnis
auch deutsche journalisten wie dennis
jale der wohl bekannteste fall wurden
inhaftiert und in solchen ländern zu
arbeiten ist es besteht für ausländische
journalisten eine große gefahr mitunter
noch viel schwieriger ist es aber
natürlich für die journalisten die aus
diesen ländern kommen und in ihrer
heimat kritisch über ihre eigene
regierung berichten wollen die macht des
staatlich gelenkten fernsehens
falschinformation produziert in russland
eine nachrichtensprecherin meldet
fälschlicherweise deutsche panzer in der
west ukraine
diese frau taucht regelmäßig im
russischen fernsehen auf in moskau
erzählt sie die ukrainische einheiten
eine familie öffentlich hingerichtet
hätten in unterschiedlichen rollen ist
sie dann internets kinder besser und mal
auf der krim
es geht darum eine kriegsführung
sozusagen auch im bereich der
information zu machen also ein
informationskrieg zu führen das ist
etwas was verschiedene staaten und
gruppierungen machen dass es aber so auf
weltpolitik und eben auch auf die
einzelnen nationen zugeschnitten wird
das ist schon eine neue qualität
kritische medien geraten regelmäßig
unter druck journalisten müssen mit
gewalt oder gezielten anschlägen rechnen
strenge internet gesetze ermöglichen
dass sperren unliebsamer webseiten es
werden immer mehr medien dort auch in
staatliche hand genommen oder in die
hand der putin treuen oligarchen und
dadurch ist eine unabhängige information
und einordnung kaum noch möglich
russland auf der rangliste der
pressefreiheit platz 149 von 180 und die
türkei seit der niederschlagung des
putschversuchs gegen regierung und
justiz härter denn je gegen kritische
journalisten vor
da sind etliche kolleginnen und kollegen
ins gefängnis gekommen
sie haben angst manche machen aufrecht
noch ihre arbeit aber sie müssen immer
damit rechnen vielleicht am nächsten tag
schon im knast zu setzen und das ist
natürlich nicht gut für gesellschaft
nicht gut für demokratie 367 tage
verbrachte deniz yücel in haft bis heute
weiß er nicht genau warum während sich
die freilassung von julian sitzen andere
journalisten weiter in türkischer haft
heraus die sind herausgeber der welt
dennis mitchell hat damals auch schon
für die welt geschrieben da war für die
welt dort vor ort das ist eine bestimmte
gefahr besteht ist natürlich klar in so
einem land in der situation waren sie
dennoch überrascht dass jemand wie
erdogan auch bei ausländischen
journalisten so hart durchgegriffen hat
so vorgegangen ist und die man wieder
das schönste hotel inhaftiert hat
wir haben das befürchtet also das ist
ein risiko war war erkennbar der spitze
sich was zug und deswegen haben wir noch
mal wieder zurückgeholt dann haben wir
gedacht hat er auch selbst gedacht dass
ich das die situation haben wir ein
bisschen entspannt hat erst wieder
zurückgegangen wurde dann in heft
inhaftiert das war eine ganz bittere
geschichte muss man wirklich sagen und
dass das so lange dauern würde haben wir
damals auch nicht erwartet aber es hat
sich einfach eine große solidarität und
das finde ich immer in solchen fällen
wichtig unter den medien also über alle
grenzen hinweg
ich meine dass man sozusagen der
kampagne zur freilassung eines
ehemaligen kollegen bei der taz von der
welt mit sozusagen gemeinsam geführt
wird
das hätte man sich auch nicht vorstellen
können aber ich glaube das war eine ganz
große leistung dass das dass alle
beteiligten hingekriegt haben aber man
kann daran sehen das ist ein gewaltiges
risiko aus diesen ländern zu berichten
das ist keine frage
und das ist natürlich für leute deren
wurzeln in diesen ländern ist ist es
natürlich noch problematischer weil sie
natürlich nicht nur allein da hingehen
sollen auch nur familie haben verwandte
haben
das heißt also sozusagen die
möglichkeiten gegen die dann vorzugehen
sind noch sehr viel größer
also das war schon eine sache auf die
hätten wir gerne verzichten ich gesagt
das andere beispiel russland baby wie
ist das für russische journalisten wie
viel pressefreiheit ist in russland
überhaupt noch möglich
das system ist eine information zu
autokratie kann man sagen die mithilfe
des staatsfernsehens über liebt es geht
weniger um akute repression denn um ein
herbeiführen von angst und einen
herbeiführen von selbstzensur
ich habe in den vergangenen jahren immer
wieder erlebt einer unserer
interviewpartner in der ost ukraine des
vergangenen sommer jetzt vom russischen
staatsfernsehen vorgeführt worden ist
dort verhaftet wurden eingesperrt wurden
gefoltert worden und hat dann ein zwangs
geständnis das er für die ukraine
spionieren würde internet abgegeben
ich kenne diesen mann ich weiß dass das
nicht stimmt ich weiß dass ein
journalist ist ein anderer
interviewpartner ist vergangenes jahr im
sommer in der zentralafrikanischen
republik umgekommen weil er zum thema
privatarmeen schuldner annähen der
russlands recherchiert hat wiederum
mantra interviewpartners in der ukraine
um gekommen also gekommen dass sie haben
ständig damit sie haben oft auch von
einem informationskrieg gesprochen und
es sind eben schon stichworte wie trolle
bots gefallen was passiert da in solchen
ländern aber auch in deutschland ja in
der digitalen welt
was sind wir wenn sie wenn sie kurz
zusammenfassen was was sind bots sind
trolle auf die wir inzwischen in solchen
informations kriegen stoßen
es gibt natürlich groß angelegte des
informationskampagnen und die eu ist
gerade eben nicht sehr gut aufgestellt
was das betrifft die länder auch nicht
wir brauchen eigentlich eine höhere
digital kompetenz um nachverfolgen zu
können können woher kommen diese sachen
und was kann man machen die sozialen
netzwerke müssten stärker kooperieren
wobei das auch eine schwierige frage ist
gibt man da die entscheidung darüber was
sind eigentlich wahrheiten was und lügen
in die hände von unternehmen also wir
stehen eigentlich noch am anfang dieser
diskussion aber es ist klar dass er viel
mehr gemacht werden muss und die eu die
kompetenzen da auch ausbauen muss
gleichzeitig muss man natürlich in den
einzelnen ländern gucken wie kann man
medien und wie kann man bürgerinnen und
bürger da auch stärken weil er teilweise
die mediengesetze dort so verändert
werden dass das was da passiert unter
dem gesetz geschieht das heißt kann man
bürgerjournalisten stärken vielleicht
auch internationales recht anzuwenden um
gegen verstöße vorzugehen die eu kann
schauen wie kann man unabhängige medien
in den
stärken das sind wichtige sachen frau
heraus hat schon die solidarität erwähnt
aber wie viel kann man auch ein paar
punkte vorschläge aber wie wichtig muss
das thema pressefreiheit dann für uns
sein und journalisten zum einen aber
auch für die politik also wie deutlich
muss man an so einer stelle
beispielsweise als journalist haltung
haben oder sich dafür einsetzen und sei
es in kommentaren
wie die politiker handeln sollte ja ich
glaube für die pressefreiheit sollte man
so viel solidarität auch bringen wie
möglich ich habe aber schon den eindruck
dass gerade in den letzten jahren wenn
ich jetzt auch mal auf deutsche
politiker gucke es da viel solidarität
gegeben hat also interessanterweise ist
durch die angriffe dies auch viel von
der kfd gab eher ein wie soll ich sagen
zusammenrücken der anderen parteien
passiert die schon den wert der
pressefreiheit sehr hoch gehalten haben
und jetzt kann man in die türkei und
nach russland gucken aber man kann ja
auch direkt irgendwie in unserem
nachbarland österreich wo armin wolf ja
immer wieder in den fokus der apple
gerät da erlebe ich jetzt schon auch
eine solidarität auch von deutschen
journalisten gegenüber armin wolf das
ist auch inhaltlich noch einmal näher
und für uns genau man kann es dann auch
noch ein sprachlich nach war fast in
rufweite kann nicht immer kann und ich
glaube dass es das ist immer wieder
wichtig ist das ist das ist so blöd ja
das ist auch so schwer zu vermitteln
aber dieses wort pressefreiheit ist so
ein wort es ist irgendwie immer so im
raum aber sich zu überlegen und ich habe
das damals auch erlebt als ich diese
geschichte für ein panorama an zum
beispiel angeguckt aber die geschichte
des kritischen journalismus wie viel wie
viel stärker das gebraucht hat und wie
viele journalisten auch dafür gekämpft
haben dass man halt heute in diesem land
jeden alles fragen kann ja du kannst du
jeden politiker gehen und ihnen ein
mikro unter die nase halten und sagen
und ihnen die kritische frage stellen
uns dem unternehmer ohne dass da
irgendwas passiert und ich glaube das
nehmen wir alles für selbstverständlich
dass ist es aber gar nicht und das kann
man gar nicht so hoch
loben wie man es nun muss ich meine über
die pressefreiheit nicht primär die
pressefreiheit des journalisten ist das
ist ein mittel seine gesellschafter
gesellschaft und der bevölkerung alles
zu erfahren was es gibt so ist und
kritik stärkte eben die demokratie
kritik stärkt das demokratische
bewusstsein wenn ich jetzt in die usa
schaue und gerade den fall der
finnischen journalistin jessica euro
mehr für gegenwärtige dann wiederum habe
ich angst wie es in den usa um die
pressefreiheit bestellt ist ganz kurz
eine erläuterung der chicago ist eine
eine finnische journalistin die sich mit
den russischen treu fabriken beschäftigt
hat als eine der ersten internationalen
groß angelegte recherche gemacht hat zu
diesen troll fabriken und die aber auch
zum beispiel in sozialen medien auf
twitter auch sehr sehr kritisch
gegenüber us-präsident gewesen ist
als sie erfahren hat dass sie einen
preis bekommt vom us außenamt den
international women of college award hat
sie sich natürlich sehr gefreut und umso
erstaunter war sie dass dieser preis
offenbar zurückgezogen wurde
aufgrund ihrer kritischen tweets zur
politik des amerikanischen präsidenten
ich denke das ist ein beispiel das war
leider keine zeit mehr
aber wir haben lange diskutiert ein
beispiel zum zum schluss zum tag der
pressefreiheit heute ich glaube wir
könnten noch lange weiter diskutieren
über vieles wenn man versucht einiges
aufzuarbeiten und auch zu schauen welche
herausforderungen ist heute gibt und
durch die sozialen netzwerke ich danke
ihnen allen in der runde für die
diskussion ich danke ihnen für ihr
interesse
bei uns heute zu diesem thema das war
unsere runde zum internationalen tag der
pressefreiheit wie immer für eine besser
informierte republik
[Musik]